well my great inspiration in my life
were sort of two forces I think one was
religion which is very very important
particularly for my mother and father
but also for the members of our family
and has been incredibly important in
terms of my life particularly facing
some of the real challenging times that
I've had to face members of the my
family that had been lost and other
kinds of tragedies and also the role of
family we were large less being a large
a family I was the youngest of nine the
last to come along sat at the little
table on the side of the room always had
to battle to get my views across or to
be able to express it but I had
extraordinary role models my father who
was very ambitious for his children and
was a great disappear was the safe-haven
devoted to her faith and also the love
of history and her children my older
brothers who were great heroes of mine
and were inspiring figures all the way
through my life also demonstrated to me
that the political process could work
and could be responsive to people's
needs and challenges my sisters who in
their own way were not elected to any
office but also we're very important in
terms of their own commitment in
expanding opportunity for people my
sister Eunice Shriver the founder
Special Olympics now in 144 countries
and going to be world focus in China in
just a few weeks from now my sister Jean
who worked for very special arts
programs which has been so important in
helping people with the disabilities and
also who are artists to work and
collaborate together and my other
sisters
and I was also inspired by a an older
sister rosemary who was mentally
retarded as she was a very important
figure in our family and she was very
included and I think from the earliest
days I recognize the that she was a
rather special individual and I could
see how my mother and father and how my
brothers and sisters reacted to her and
I think it was probably extraordinary
force in my life about recognizing the
value and the special grace that
individuals have that have physical or
challenges in this instant mental
retardation and the importance of their
value and what they could give to the
family and also the recognition that
people out there in our society have a
special needs and they as a as a family
and as a as a country in a society we
ought to be able to try and reach out to
our fellow citizens and respond to those
kinds of of human needs
oh sure yeah I do I think there are
those that in the in the Congress
elected office I see them I think they
are in legislative offices as well I
think they're out there and in the in
the in the countryside it's not
necessarily always in the house of the
Senate I think state legislators we see
it we see it with district attorneys we
see it in the local communities people
they one of the events that I'm always
inspired of is when Caroline Kennedy my
niece gives the Profile in Courage Award
day each a year to an elected official
and it's I've been on the judging as a
judge in there and we spend a lot of
time in looking over these final
recommendations and it's inspiring about
what how willing people are to stand up
and and take a tough decision